[Música]
no
buenas tardes a todos guau entrar con
seguridad me dijeron tengo un cagazo que
no me traen cuerpo para que este
cuadernito al pedo porque tiene puros
garabatos así que no lo voy a entender
nada de acá arriba bueno
principalmente viene a contarles una
historia pero quiero proponerles primero
un ejercicio
todos tenemos propuestas a fin de año
depende de cada uno o en el cumpleaños
hacemos una balance del año
yo quiero preguntarles a cada uno de
ustedes y que levanten la mano quien se
propuso algo hoy acá veo que hay muchos
chicos bueno quiero que levante la mano
quien se propuso algo hoy quien se
propuso algo el lunes porque de repente
nada el domingo como es como un guanaco
y te comes todo el asado vino
postre y si mañana empiezo la dieta
bueno me alegra ver muchas manos
levantadas felicito y espero que puedan
cumplir con eso
bueno vengo a contarles ahora
una historia de vida en carne propia
es la historia y se inicia de chico yo
lo que quiero es que esto pueda
relacionarlo un poquito con ustedes y
así les va a servir yo vengo de un
núcleo familiar de padres separados lo
cual para mí es importante iniciar la
charla con esto porque si bien me dio
inseguridades más adelante me dio otras
seguridades en otros aspectos
lo cual es importante para todos
nosotros poder tener la oportunidad de
de darte darnos cuenta de eso no es
cierto cuando cuando sufrimos una cosa
así hoy por hoy por supuesto tengo una
excelente relación con todos mis padres
y no tengo ningún problema inclusive
ellos me dieron y estoy agradecido a eso
la historia comienza cuando terminó la
secundaria y me siento con mi papá
y me dice bueno hijo llegó el momento
que vas a hacer
vas a estudiar vas a trabajar entonces
yo nunca fui un estudiante burro por ahí
también alguna sencilla quién o quién
fue un burro en la escuela a ver que
levante la mano a quien le costó mucho
en la escuela a quien le cuesta
actualmente tienen que estudiar chicos
porque si no van a tener que trabajar
como yo y es mucho mejor estudiar así
que les aconsejo eso pero de cualquier
manera también trabajando uno puede
cumplir sus objetivos muchos de acá o
algunos de ustedes puede llegar a estar
queriendo iniciar un objetivo entonces
yo cuando terminé la secundaria me puse
a trabajar ahí se iniciaba el primer
objetivo mi papá como
haciéndose menos me regaló un vehículo
utilitario pero también era para
trabajar porque él tenía un camión así
que yo con este vehículo utilitario
empecé a recorrer las calles de esquel y
vendía vino papas cebolla
zanahoria bueno lo que lo que traiga a
mí en el camino lo vendía bueno así
estuve un año más o menos y concluir la
etapa cuando tuvimos una diferencia
bastante grande y me fui de casa con 19
años
ay me tenía que hacer valor por sí mismo
y tenía que conseguir trabajo así que lo
primero que hice poder fue ir a ver a un
distribuidor para el cual nosotros
trabajábamos y llevábamos cerveza a dos
localidades cercanas ambiente y río
amayo automáticamente que ver con
trabajo la persona está sabía que yo
trabajaba siempre fui muy responsable
con el trabajo quiero que sepan que esto
se lo digo con total humildad pero fui
muy meticuloso
a más allá de que trabajara para otra
empresa yo siempre la tomé como como
propia siempre todos los días trataba de
hacer algo mejor y algo que sume así
pasaron cinco años todos los años no se
evaluaban la empresa trabajaba con un
manual que tenía varias preguntas y se
evaluarán la parte de venta
administración y logística bueno yo
estaba en la parte de ventas
y bueno por suerte tenía un supervisor
muy bueno que con mucho cariño
y siempre me dieron las evaluaciones
positivas lo cual en un momento es este
distribuidor no tenía problemas
económicos o sea no necesitaba la
distribuidora para subsistir y tampoco
quería trabajar con ese manual que les
hablé reciben no quería atenerse a las
reglas de esa impresión de esa empresa
multinacional entonces sabíamos que la
empresa que la distribuidora donde yo
trabajaba cerraba y este supervisor me
propuso
me preguntó
ya capaz de ser supervisor de ventas
entonces yo con 24 años
digo ahora tengo 37 no sé si se dieron
cuenta 24 en ese momento pero provisorio
como
como hemos supervisor no lo creía o sea
no lo podía creer que yo fuera ocupar el
lugar de él
siempre tengan confianza de ustedes es
muy importante tener confianza
con la confianza podemos lograr todo
pero pero realmente tienen que sentirlo
entonces en ese momento
no lo creí tanto pero fue realidad
cuando me llamaron un día de buenos
aires- ofreciéndome el puesto tuve una
reunión en bariloche recuerdo la reunión
una anécdota estaba con la persona que
me estaba haciendo la entrevista
se llama bernal se llaman emails y
estábamos charlando a hernán le digo
mira todo muy bien con la venta pero yo
por de computación no hace nada
inclusive mejor viste el cpu es donde se
puede ahorrar el botón de donde se
desprende pero de verdad que no sabía
nada bueno él me dice que no era
necesario que lo que buscaban en mí era
que lleve adelante la fuerza de ventas
bueno en fin la verdad que estuve un año
y medio en bariloche y así fui
supervisor de ventas
fue todo muy lindo experiencia muy linda
y ahí me pool y en la parte
administrativa todo esto que les voy
contando sirve para lo último para lo
que voy a finalizar para cerrar la idea
para que ustedes se den cuenta de que
las cosas se pueden hacer en la vida de
que se puede lograr no es necesario
estudiar más más allá de que yo los
impulsó a hacerlo los impulsos estudian
que estudian se pueden lograr los
objetivos
bueno la cuestión que como les digo me
fue bien en esta etapa laboral después
de un tema personal me volví parece que
él con una mano atrás el adelante otra
vez otra anécdota les cuento yo nunca
supe llegar a fin de mes
por favor levanten la mano los que nunca
llegan a fin de mes con el sueldo porque
no muy bien bueno está bien
nunca llegué a fin de mes el 20 empezaba
a pedir adelantado y los primeros días
del mes cobraba lo demás pero bueno no
era buena administrativa en ese momento
tenía un auto en el año 2009 un auto 94
tenía un carro tenía una moto y tenía un
gomón que lo usaba para pescar en la
buap y me encanta la pesca así que
será todo mi capital como iba iniciar
una empresa con eso bueno tenía un no
tenía plata no tenía efectivo
con silicio la empresa sin efectivo
bueno yo tuve la suerte de ponerme en
contacto con una fábrica la cual me
pidió unos requisitos por supuesto y me
fío la mercadería si me la mandó a
crédito así que yo me tenía que
convertir ese auto modelo 94 en un
utilitario porque en un auto no se puede
mi mercadería
así que había visto una camionetita acá
en un barrio estaba bien una camionetita
del mismo modelo que el auto y mi viejo
es un tipo muy efusivos esto se me dice
pero si no no podrá comprar la camioneta
de juan a trelew esté impecable si no
sabéis lo que es inyectarle impecable
anda comprarle la camioneta juan bueno a
600 kilómetros le digo tengo la
camioneta cinco cuadras acá
si anda se me caso antes comprar la
camiseta a juan que la tiene era de un
minera viejita que iba a comprar el pan
bueno me voy a esta tregua hago 600
kilómetros en el colectivo por supuesto
ya el pasaje me lo tuvo que papá porque
no tenía plata ni para el pasaje y lo
que les digo es la verdad cuando llegue
a trelew de repente me encuentro con
juan sufría adicciones
cuando me di cuenta en ese momento pues
también no tiene nada que ver con
ustedes pero de repente cuando tuve que
conocer la camioneta estamos en buen
estado tengo que reconocer que estaba en
buen estado no se la veía deteriorada
así que emprendió el viaje para esquel y
empieza a tener desperfectos mecánicos
andando en vehículo desde chico y arriba
de un camión había lo que me estaba
pasando se me venía fundiendo el motor
de la camioneta
a mitad de camino en trelew yo ya tenía
la mercadería que venía fijada y le
había firmado tres documentos de mil
pesos a juan en ese momento que era
mucha plata
a mitad de camino
se me funde una maleta se fundió así que
me tiré al costado del camino lo había
llamado en el pueblo anterior a mi papá
por teléfono y le había dicho que se me
venía fundiendo la camioneta
llorando
la verdad que ya era un desazón para mí
era una desilusión porque estaba
literalmente fundido
se va a buscar me ha metido hasta es que
la camioneta le arreglaron el motor él
me prestó la plata tuve que vender el
gomón en cuotas a un amigo
bueno en fin salía salí de nuevo a la
calle
no queda ahí la historia falta una
partecita importante salgo a la calle
empiezo a vender y empiezo a cosechar el
fruto de aquello que había sembrado
cuando vendía en ese primer utilitario
esta es la verdad de la historia este es
la fe está la camisa padecer el anterior
era la pan lactal el de los hippies sin
menospreciar a los gitanos no se compre
en ese vehículo para viajar si alguno
tiene el sueño dice ay yo quiero viajar
y lo viajar en este vehículo por la
argentina y está hasta el fin hasta el
hasta ushuaia y en el norte porque
difícilmente el vehículo llega a
trevelin le cambian el motor las que
ustedes ven bueno así que la cuestión
que éste así se inició me empecé a
trabajar empecé a andar en la calle
a cosechar el fruto que les habló que
había sembrado cuando salí a vender con
el primer utilitario la mercadería de mí
y de mi papá y después cuando con ese
distribuidor que trabaje
y la primer semana había dejado un
pedido en el quiosco del hospital para
todos somos de acá cálculo y avanzaba
por la calle 25 no para y miró así en la
esquina no venía nadie así que miro la
boleta del próximo negocio que tenía que
llevar el pedido y siento como una
explosión de repente estaba en una nube
de polvo y arriba de la vereda sin saber
cómo había pasado me habían chocado pero
me habían corrido el motor del lugar o
sea no solo me chocaron se corrió el
motor del lugar había que hacer un
trabajo muy importante la camioneta para
que vuelva a funcionar el cual me lo
realizó un chapista conocido acá es que
el que lo recuerdo con mucho cariño
porque en su momento él me dijo que no
me lo iba a arreglar pero las cosas de
la vida presten atención a esta parte 1
hay cosas que no las entiende pero yo no
soy creyente tampoco soy ateo pero
y entonces las cosas de la vida este
hombre me dijo
francisco la voy a arreglar la camioneta
primero me había dicho que no así que
bueno te la dejé a los 34 días me llamó
por teléfono y me dijo que estaba
terminada y cuando fui a buscarla no me
cobró el trabajo yo le había contado lo
que me venía pasando
así que funge esto
muy generoso de su parte y ahí empezó la
parte de donde yo digo que se fueron las
nubes se aclaró el cielo como cuando hay
una tormenta muy grande y de repente
empezamos a ver el cielo azul y todavía
las nube negra están acá pero como que
no pasaron pero que ya se empieza a
clarificar
y aquí nos empezó a dar frutos la
distribuidora empezó a dar frutos del
negocio empezamos a crecer al primer año
ya puede cambiar el vehículo en las dos
años tuvo el primer cero kilómetro todo
esto que les digo se los quiero
transmitir para que solamente para que
para que algunos de ustedes aunque uno
de ustedes se lleve algo de estos para
mí va a ser suficiente
sepan que se puede lograr a los dos años
ya vino el primer cero kilómetro tenía
un empleado que trabajaba conmigo y hoy
me cowell
hace diez años el 14 de septiembre
cumplió 10 años bueno ya somos 6
integrantes ya tenemos cuatro vehículos
y tenemos una cartera de clientes de más
de 400 clientes en toda la zona
esto que les digo me costó un huevo
realmente me costó un huevo y esas son
las siglas un poco d
de la incubadora algunos que ya me
conozcan lo saben
ahí se ve el equipo de trabajo y bueno
para cerrar quiero dejarle algunas
cositas que éste lo más importante de la
charla para mí y para todos aquellos que
estén queriendo emprender algo o los
chicos importantes han recontra
contentos con esta charla los vídeos
desde donde verán la cara están como
locos igual que con nico lo que hoy les
quiero dejar descubrir en que somos
buenos y plantear un objetivo claro
porque ellos por ejemplo si me pones a
dibujar soy un desastre
entonces o me pone a jugar al fútbol soy
malísimo vos son buenos cuando el fútbol
vos
bueno yo no yo soy malísimo sí más o
menos bueno algo que criticar es que
cuando decidan algo para hacer o sean
grandes decían algo que les vaya a
gustar para siempre a donde ustedes
piensen que se van a poder destacar y
que cada día se despierten como yo con
ganas de trabajar yo disfruto de mi
trabajo puedo decirlo así los que me
conocen lo saben
suena el despertador y saber que te va a
costar te va a mostrar un montón
despertarte de lunes a sábados ver que
por ahí tenés un amigo que trabaja de
lunes a viernes se toma todo los
feriados bueno le va a costar mucho
emprender algo personal
podéis triunfar si tenés muchas
probabilidades de triunfar pero te va a
costar y sabe que va a ser muy duro el
camino
la recompensa del pensamiento positivo
positivo acompañando de la acción o el
esfuerzo siempre seamos positivos
tratemos de no darle la vida a la gente
del alrededor muchas ideas muchas ideas
famosas fueron frustradas al principio
por gente que decía no va a funcionar
fíjate que este hombre también tiene lo
mismo y no anda muy bien hecho en esta
época lo vas a poner traten de no sé no
ser influenciado de esa manera es muy
importante
pensar en los demás pero saber que
muchas veces deberá ser egoísta
cuando tenés un emprendimiento personal
y tenés estos estos otros 33 tips antes
a veces vas a tener que ser egoísta
lamentablemente te vas a perder
cumpleaños te vas a perder algunas
fiestas te vas a pasar a ser egoísta con
vos mismo incluso
después desmontar el legado familiar y
el manual de vida inculcado esto quiere
decir que cualquiera de nosotros en un
manual de vida que nos inculcaron de
chicos cualquiera de cualquiera de
ustedes quisiera quizás parecerse a su
papá o su mamá bueno también pueden sea
ustedes mismos y decidir su camino no es
necesario parecerse a nadie más bien es
necesario parecerse a uno mismo
la fuerza de la mente y una convicción
clara mueve la potencia física esto qué
quiere decir cuando nosotros
con mucha fuerza algo pero no no haré
no hagan tanta fuerza ahora lo que les
digo no nos podemos poner a pensar que
una moto
no así no va a llegar no es que se va a
parecer yo abrí los ojos van a tener que
trabajar van a tener de los 1 2 3 4 5
tips anterior para que esos funciones
sepan que el camino del emprendedor no
es un camino fácil pero lo volvería a
elegir siempre volvería a elegir la vida
que tuve volvería a
al principio de lo que les hablé a la
niñez a eso que al principio me hizo
sufrir pero después me hizo más fuerte
lo volvería a repetir te voy a dejar por
último la inquietud de cómo empecé al
principio que se van a proponer hoy
muchas gracias